I have a buddy of mine who hooked up
with this girl yeah and they went back
and forth on line and then they got
together and he said immediately before
she even blew him she went right to his
ass all right well what any good yeah he
goes I just got off a plane
you [ __ ] disgusting travel ass what
yeah I'm like why he goes I was so
disgusted I never called her again
I never personally went to the ass went
to the ass like you know sure I'm some
ladies are bold yeah yes yeah that's a
weird move though right yeah yeah yeah
what kind of message you trying sent
some chicks of your school man
yeah man she's a desk I mean how many
guys have told their friends that kind
of a story and their friend wow that's
awesome also if she found a good girl
huh oh my god oh you don't want to do
that woof-woof-woof
mm-hmm never doing that someone in
college I only did it cuz I saw in the
movie no you know I did I got Hershey
syrup and I thought it was like kinky to
do it and then I realized as the Hershey
series Mira it just looked like she [ __ ]
all over cuz it's just liquid chocolate
so I pulled my face up in my god man it
looks like she just [ __ ] in my mouth
even though it didn't taste like it sure
looked like it
yeah that's not a good look no yeah I
look yeah that's not good I don't think
she liked it either
no she get weirded out by you now she
just likes what you want to do alrighty
all right man